if you're unfamiliar with procreate and
morpholia trace
procreate is more of a visual creator's
dream whilst morfolio trace
is a practical professional tool having
said this
which one is better for architects and
which one
is the best tool you can find
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me on this channel
we talk about technology and
architecture today we're talking about
morfolio trace and procreate
we're trying to establish which one is
the better tool for architects
first of all if you're looking to
download one of these two apps neither
of them are free
they're both best used on an ipad with a
pencil or some sort of stylus
procreate is 1499 australian
one-off payment whereas morfolio trace
is technically free to download
but it costs you about 28 australian
dollars per year
to keep the absolute premium
subscription so from a consumer level
straight away procreate is a much
cheaper product
versus more folio trace considering more
folio trace is the more expensive
premium product we'll call it we'll dive
into this section and this app
first if you want to compare it to
procreate you're welcome to scrub along
the timeline down the bottom i'll split
this up into sections so you know
exactly where you need to go
i've been using morpholio trace for a
while now and i have made a separate
video
about morfolio trace i'll try link it
down below if i remember
if not i'm sure you're going to be able
to find it pretty quickly however i've
been using it as a basic tool for
architecture
i'd usually take it into client meetings
with me and open up their drawings in
more folio trace
scale it up and then start marking all
over the drawings
i found morfolio trace to be a very
practical architectural tool
when you need to actually evaluate
drawings and utilize
a tablet versus printed paper so to put
it into perspective
morpholio trace is a great application
that's basically equivalent
to me having a big piece of printed
paper a scale ruler
and 100 million pencils with me at the
same time
it really gives me that freedom and
luxury to scale the drawing to exactly
the right size i need
take the ruler measure up bits and
pieces and mark up
and annotate drawings however i want and
see fit now this is a very basic
understanding of morpholia trace i'm not
a very good artist i'm not very good at
architectural diagrammatical drawings
but i do know how to use technology so
that makes me a little bit better
mortfolio trace has some amazing tools
straight away
you have some very basic pencils and
some very basic brushes that let you do
your job quickly and easily but one of
the best features is the stencil tools
straight away in more folio trace you
don't have to go and download any extra
bits and pieces
you can literally pick up your tablet
pick up your pencil and start using all
the built-in stencils
the stencils feature anything from
people to trees and plants all the way
to architectural sectional details brick
coursing
or even just landscape planting and
trees so having all these stencils
pre-built in means you can open up a
floor plan
plop in some furniture move around some
landscaping
and create whatever you need to do on
that actual architectural drawing
out of all the tools and features in
morpholia trays i do believe that the
ruler and the scale ruler
are one of the best features available
on the app
this feature isn't available on
procreate and we'll get to procreate in
just a second
but having that ruler and having that
ability to quickly scale
and use the ruler to understand the
scale of any drawing
as long as it has some sort of scale on
it is really fundamental and pivotal
i try to utilize this more as a business
tool
than anything else it lets me quickly
move from meeting to meeting and
understand
exactly what needs to be done so if you
need an app that can
quickly and easily take you from one
meeting to another
and pretend like you're carrying 100
million drawings under your arm
well then morfolio trace is exactly what
you're looking for now on the other hand
we have procreate which is the cheaper
competitor
but it's also the market leader in
instagram ads and influencers and
everything so procreate has been popping
up
everywhere and to be honest i hadn't
really used procreate too much
until i saw a whole bunch of my friends
and colleagues start using procreate
and talking about how fantastic it is
and if i'm going to be honest it is
bloody powerful it is basically like
having a mini photoshop
in your app but much better than the
photoshop app
it's a lot more intuitive and it's a lot
more pushed
towards that artistic flair and that
artistic design style
so if you are somebody who is very good
at
art and can do architectural
diagrammatical drawings procreate is
absolutely perfect whereas morfolio
trace is kind of more for people like me
who struggle with that architectural
documentation side
from a 2d pencil kind of drawing i'm
phenomenal at 3d architectural
visualization
and construction documentation on a
computer but you get me to do anything
freehand i'm pretty average
so that's me being 100 honest procreate
on the other hand
gives you that great ability to do it on
an ipad
if you have those skills just like
morfolio trace you can import whatever
you need
and quickly start drawing and marking up
over that document
in procreate what you can't do like i've
already mentioned is scale that drawing
and
put a scale ruler to it so if you do
have this drawing open in front of
clients
you might not have any idea what size
dimensions you need to have
unless those drawings are scaled in some
way shape or form but most of the time
it's a near impossible task to get the
scale accurate
procreate also doesn't have a million
and one different stencils built in
so there's no architectural details
already plugged in
ready to go for you it does on the other
hand have some amazing
brushes and pencils so you have a couple
hundred i think pre-installed
straight away that you can choose from i
found the light flares and the water to
be
really really amazing for all of your
architectural renders that you're trying
to improve
and because procreate is such a
well-known app there's a million and one
different brushes and pencil sets out
there that you can go out and download
and buy
i know eric over at 30 by 40 runs an
amazing youtube channel
on architecture and architecture design
as well if you aren't following him go
check him out he's phenomenal
he has his own procreate pack for
architects and designers
i haven't downloaded i'm sorry eric i'm
too cheap but there is some amazing
brushes in there
that you can go and actually showcase
and use for yourself
if you have the time to set up procreate
properly and create your own brushes or
download a few from somewhere else it is
a phenomenal app
it has so much power and so much ability
to create incredible pieces of artwork
now if you're trying to elevate any of
your drawings that have been exported
out of a
architectural package you can quickly
import them and start utilizing that
floor plan and
creating some artistic documents that's
kind of what procreate does better than
morpholio trace
it gives you that ability to be an
artist and to have free reins however
you want
but it's also a con if you don't know
what you're doing whereas morpholia
trace is kind of a little bit more
guided
it lets you emulate that architectural
style drawing
instead of having to actually learn how
to do it so to wrap it up
procreate is an incredible artistic
architectural tool
if you already have the skills as an
artist whereas morfolio trace gives you
that ability
to do all of your architectural work
without having to think too hard about
the project
so overall i think both apps have their
own pros and cons i think
both apps are actually necessary for
architects in a real world environment
but if you had to choose one and this is
me just speaking personally it would be
more folio trace
because it is a much more intuitive app
as an architect
anyway that's all for me today guys
thanks so much for watching i hope you
enjoyed the video if you did
make sure you smash that subscribe
button down below this month i've tried
to generate as much content as possible
for you guys
so i've done 28 videos in 28 days
usually it would be i'll see you next
monday but in this case
i'll see you tomorrow